A little bit about me...
You might not know who I am.
I grew up in this place called Dubai.
It's not part of Illinois. (I was once asked that).
It's actually part of the Middle East.
It's in this country called the United Arab Emirates.
This is what it looked like when I was 10.
So now you know how old I am.
Just stare at the screen for a minute...
This is 1991.
This is 2005.
Now look at those 4 buildings right there. Those haven't changed.
Woooah.
Hopefully you're drinking and this looks really cool.
I'll just go back and forth a few times.
So why am I showing this to you?
The reason I'm showing this to you is because
in a very short span of time we can actually transform our environment really really quickly.
This is amazing technology, amazing innovation, amazing engineering.
It's also to me, growing up here,
it's very difficult to look at this
and sort of wonder "where did the desert go?"
What happened to my landscape?
They're building ski resorts in the middle of the desert.
There are 3 so far. More designed to be built.
This is what it's going to look like.
So it's sort of an oil to ice conversion.
This is The Palm Resort. Everyone gets beach access.
Who doesn't love the beach?
This is a photograph that I took. And this was my last visit to the UAE.
It's very difficult for me to actually go back
because it doesn't feel or look like the place I grew up in.
So this is a photograph that I took from the shore
of a ship dumping sand into the ocean to make land.
And this is how the shoreline has transformed over time.
This is 1973, 1990, and 2006
So do you see the palm islands and the world islands? It's pretty amazing, right?
So in a very very short period of time, the entire environment has completely transformed itself.
And so this is where I grew up.
This is my background.
So I came to the United States in 2000.
And I was at University of Illinois Urbana–Champaign.
There are some alums here,
we went  to school together,
and they found me here.
Amazing.
I studied physics and math.
And i was like, alright, physics is amazing.
But I really wanted to work on climate change.
I really wanted to work on sustainability.
The United Arab Emirates has
a very large environmental footprint.
So does the United States.
And so the year that I started by PhD was 2004.
So I'm going to kind of give you the story of my life.
Then I'm going to embed that
into the story of the work that I'm doing.
So in 2004, the same month that I started my PhD,
this paper came out in Science magazine
by Pacala and Socolow.
And the first sentence in their paper was
Alright humanity already has all of the solutions
we need to solve the climate problem.
We don't have to wait. We have the technology we need.
We can solve it today.
Humanity already has all these solutions.
Then... why haven't we done anything about it?
We still have this problem happening right now.
So what do they say in their paper?
So this was a kind of back of the envelope exercise...
They said, if we want to stabilize emissions,
and then we want to stabilize concentration,
let's just think of it in terms of a variety of technologies.
A variety of things we can do.
So they said alright imagine each
of these technologies providing a wedge.
A sort of one gigaton of carbon decrease per year
everything from efficiency and conservation
renewable electricity, carbon capture and storage,
reforestation, nuclear energy, biomass, fuel switching, so on and so forth. This is just to stabilize emissions.
And then after that we need to actually
decrease our emissions to net removal.
They put forward this entire portfolio.
I said, great. Why aren't we doing that stuff?
What they also said in their paper is
improvements in efficiency and conservation
offer the greatest potential to solve this problem.
So i started to dedicating my career from that point on
to figuring out why is it that we don't
incorporate efficiency and conservation in our life?
And I've been focusing primarily in the United States.
So what's been going on?
As you can tell our carbon dioxide concentration
which is basically how much carbon dioxide
there is in the atmosphere
has been going steadily up.
So it just keeps increasing every year.
So every year that I teach my course
I have to keep updating the numbers.
They keep going up!
Every time I teach that one section of my class
it's like internal pain. I have to go home
and have myself a nice gin & tonic at the end of the day.
How do we solve this?
Then when Al Gore came up with the Inconvenient Truth
he was trying to keep it under 400 parts per million.
So just as per cent is out of a hundred,
parts per million is out of a million.
So we're trying to keep this at below doubling.
And we just passed 400 parts per million.
So that is the challenge that we're faced with today.
So how do you visualize this in terms of temperature?
This is a beautiful graphic that Ed Hawkins did.
It's basically a color map.
Looking at the average temperature in the United States.
And each stripe is one year.
As you can probably tell (you may need to squint from the back of the room), it's going from bluish to reddish.
Folks in the back of the room, do you see that?
So that's what's happening
with our average annual temperature.
We're getting warmer.
So in trying to figure out why we don't act,
I asked 700 people across the United States,
What is the single most important problem
for you today?
What is the most important problem
for you in the future?
And what do think is the world's
biggest problem today and  in the future?
And here's the data. This data was collected in 2010.
So the #1 problem that America faces today
is the economy. Alright?
The #1 problem that the world faces in the future
is climate change.
So the problem there is that the future
always happens in the future!
How do we speed that shit up?
So how do we make the future happen today?
And that's why I'm really interested
in stories and storytelling.
I'm interested in how we compress time?
How do we imagine what
the future's going to look like, today?